her nickname in high school
was calamity jane
and she only discovered years later that
it was one of her teachers who gave it
to her
so i'm not sure where that of what that
implies so everyone please welcome epec
good morning everyone i'm very happy to
be here
and to be sharing this work with you
today that i recently completed so it's
fresh out of the oven um and before i
begin i like to acknowledge my
collaborators on this work doctors
caceres jackman um odd lumbacking and
miss suera at columbia university
okay so i'm an associate research
scientist at the data science institute
at columbia university and
i feel in my research i focus a lot on
physical activity and it's subset of
exercise as forms of symptom
self-management across a wide range of
chronic conditions
to this end one of the questions that i
investigate is how do we best leverage
patient generated physical activity data
from various mobile health technologies
to make better sense of them
these could include things like actively
track patient data from smartphone apps
for example as well as passively
collected physical activity data from
things like your fitbit your apple watch
so wearable
trackers activity trackers which is what
i'm going to focus on today
so one thing to know or to keep in mind
with physical activity as a health
behavior is that it is a longitudinal
behavior that is meant to be done on a
consistent basis at least hopefully
that's the goal
[Music]
so when i am investigating physical
activity i want to know it is
temporality
i.e how this relationship might unfold
over time for a given individual
moreover everyone has a unique
relationship with physical activity
meaning this relationship might unfold
differently for different individuals
so i also want to know
in what ways these profiles these
trajectories might vary across
individuals but why why should we care
about these differences because knowing
this uh
first and foremost would allow us to
design
interventions and self-management
strategies that are tailored at the
right level whether that is at the
individual level or subgroup level so it
could be
disease subtypes or different
demographic groups etc
now to further motivate this idea of
studying the temporality of physical
activity behavior consider the physical
activity guidelines and you might have
come across these at the doctor's office
or at various online sources
which historically have focused on some
sort of uh
aggregated total stem so
you might have come across the
quintessential 150 minutes of moderate
to gross physical activity per week
right like to keep to maintain good
cardiovascular health or to get a
certain number of steps each day right
and these guidelines even though they're
useful to give us some sort of a
benchmark
they do not keep in mind they do not
give us any recommendations as to
the timing of the activity so it doesn't
matter that i distribute my activity
throughout the day or can i just
accumulate all of the 150 minutes in one
go in the morning and then sit the rest
of the day
and more research more recent research
is actually indicating that yes indeed
it does matter
when you do or whether or not you're
distributing your activity so if you are
going to the gym in the morning running
for an hour and then sitting for the
remainder of the day i'm sorry to let
you know that you are cancelling out all
the health benefits you are conferring
in the morning
so
so the more we send you might actually
have seen these um phrases break your
sedentary time to like get up every hour
walk around so like this is where those
recommendations are coming from so
we're finding out that it is actually
instead of focusing on getting the this
higher intensity accumulated in at least
10 minute bouts that if we just focus on
getting any activity so any intensity
could be light but
more frequently distributed across the
time course it might be more beneficial
okay
okay now
let's convert this resource question
into a data question
what i'm trying to figure out is
can i identify homogeneous latent
profiles of physical activity
trajectories or clusters or groups in
samples of
that are interpretable actionable
potentially clinically
relevant
even in and that are detectable even in
mixed samples of patients so that the
results are generalizable right
and of course there there's a whole
plethora of clustering methods out there
that are that have
um that are commonly used and have been
published on in the literature
however existing physical activity
clustering studies have typically cl
aggregated physical data at some level
either at the day level or weak level
in which case the unit of analysis in
these studies is is a scalar it's there
it's individual data points even if it's
aggregated
even if it's an aggregate of
various time points
so how do we build a model where the
unit of analysis is an entire curve of
data points instead right the whole
trajectory
okay
enter package funfem
so one way to address this
question is to use a clustering method
that relies on what are called
discriminator functional mixture models
which the font fan package allows us to
do
so this is a probabilistic clustering
technique so it's doing soft clustering
and what the model does is that it
models a set of observed
curves or individuals into k homogeneous
groups
or clusters
based on their similarity so some sort
of a common functional subspace
as as they're called so in the um
these models the fms are a part of the
larger family of functional data
analytic methods what makes them
unique is that they consider the whole
the unit of analysis is a curve an
entire path of discrete observations
data points it's a whole curve is one
unit of analysis
um and therefore it allows you to they
allow you to consider the whole
temporal aspect of whatever variable
you're interested in studying so as you
can see that this makes them
particularly useful in this case
scenario with this question that i'm
trying to answer
okay um and ffm's further a lot um
their part they have parsimony in that
they allow you to
distinguish between these trajectories
uh without requiring an extensive set of
variables so you can cluster in a single
variable because the the added temporal
dimension
the time dimension actually increases
the number of protectors because you're
clustering on that many time points
okay so let me tell you a little bit
about the study sample and the data
source i'm working with a sample of 133
adults
ages across the lifespan so it's a
pretty wide range and with respect to
health
status there's a little bit of a
variability there too
these were all individuals enrolled into
a um
study
at the school of nursing oklahoma
university by my collaborators that i
listed in the beginning of my talk that
that aim to study
health disparities in latinx adults with
with
certain various commodities so i have
for example older adults who might be
who are living with hiv i might have
younger physically healthy adults who
might have some psychological stress
related
symptoms but otherwise physically
healthy and so forth and a lot of them
are at increased risk for some sort of a
sleep disturbance for example but not
necessarily clinical
sleep disorder okay so they're not all
healthy young adults
for physical activity data i am using
acta life factor graph devices these are
research grade resworn activity trackers
they provide a whole range of variables
for use
for
interoperability and relevance i focus
on steps so sedentary minutes that would
be
sitting low metabolic
activity
activities when you're awake so sitting
standing
and so forth as well as different
intensities of activities so
light intensity that would be a
leisurely walk in the park moderate
intensity would be a brisk walk on the
sidewalk that we at least see in in new
york
vigorous intensity would be
running to catch the bus as it's leaving
the bus stop and then very vigorous
intensity would be sprinting to catch
the subway as the door is closing
because the next subway does not arrive
for another seven minutes okay
okay so those are my variables okay so
the first step when we're dealing with
functional data is to reconstruct this
um
sample path of observations discrete
observations or data points into some
functional form that's where the name
comes from so this funfam algorithm
considers assumes that the sample paths
belong to a finite dimensional space
spanned by some basis functions
um and basis functions are used to
or a similar way of saying this is we
use basis functions to basically smooth
and
synthesize the trend in each
um each path each curve so then it
becomes um so then one current becomes
one unit of analysis each individual
represented by a curve okay
and the whole the complete observational
time period you can divide into
sub-intervals so you can specify at what
points how much curvature you want so
this is the exact same idea as when
you're smoothing in other
model models
but you have to pick the right balance
between over smoothing and under
smoothing how much willingness you want
right so you don't want to over smooth
so that you're missing out on
potentially important trends but then
you don't want to
um under smooth then you're picking up
noise that's not really a meaningful
trend
okay so these sub intervals in this case
are called bases and then the
breakpoints are nots
okay so the purpose of our analysis what
do the data look like to that each
individual is represented by 24 data
points each representing one hour so i'm
using 24-hour data from everyone
for each individual
the smoothing functions and the number
of knots that provide the best for the
data are picked based on
by trying different models and then
using the bic index to pick the um the
model that provides the best fit for the
data the ic index is what's recommended
specifically for this model
and then the cluster separation the
goodness of fit and the
validation of the separation of the
clusters are done by
oh the spline so the most commonly used
basis functions in this scenario are the
b splines and the fourier function so
those are what i tried
and i tried up to 12 knots
and k of two to six clusters okay
um to the
once you try different models and i i go
through the typical pipeline of using
both
visual inspection of the basis plus to
make sure that the except the functional
space separation is actually separate
and that there is no overlap as well as
some postdoc tests to
make sure that there are actually
significant differences in patterns
and then i looked at
some day level summaries as well to see
how it compares when we aggregate versus
look at the trajectories
okay
um
so the results of the models indicated
four distinct homogeneous physical
activity phenotypes
and moderate intensity
actively provided the best separation
between clusters i should also mention
that in the sample nobody had any
vigorous or very vigorous intensity
activity so any activity they had was
either a flight or moderate intensity
so nobody is running to catch the bus or
the subway
okay
so and this is the
right so this this plot is the plot the
orientation of the
the functions um i mean the orientation
of the coefficients according to the
basis functions
okay
so this figure shows a 24-hour
trajectories for each of the identified
phenotypes to provide a visual
description for each of them phenotype 1
was characterized by an initial increase
in activity levels in earlier times of
the day so around late morning followed
by a gradual decline in activity over
the remainder of the day um
so these individuals you can think of
this as the the typical nine-to-five
working professional archetype like
they're more active in in the earlier
times of the day they're working and
then they come back and they kind of
just sit around until that time
phenotype two was the oh and phenotype
one was the largest of the of the
clusters phenotype two was is the
smallest and these are also the most
active um
most likely to be the most active out of
all the phenotypes they have the highest
levels of all types of physical activity
and the least amount of sedentary time
and compared to phenotype 2 they were
more likely to have later bedtimes
now phenotype 3 is the most sedentary
phenotype it was characterized by just
very little amounts of activity
throughout the day
and mostly being sedentary
and these the age associated with this
group was also
a little slightly older than the others
okay so phenotype fourth is distinctly
characterized by
a more evenly distributed activity level
throughout the day and as well as shift
in circadian patterns so these people
were more likely to wake up later and
also go to bed later
okay now let's put these numbers into
perspective and we can do this by using
published um cutoff values for steps and
different intensities of activities and
some proposed um activity zones
but these act proposed activity zones
are just for um
kind of in to provide some intuitive
description they're not clinically
defined they're not very strict um
zones so don't think of them as like a
clinical diagnosis or anything so based
on these provided cutoffs phenotype 1
would consist of individuals who are
active or somewhat active based on that
10k steps per day cut off right so it's
a mix of individuals
on the other hand phenotype 2 and 4
would represent highly active
individuals and most likely to
accumulate the recommended weekly dose
of
moderate to vigorous physical activity
they're accumulating quite over the
the recommended dose of 150 minutes
in contrast phenotype 3 would fall into
our membership to phenotype 3 would fall
in the categories of sedentary or low
active
so
and most likely to
not meet the recommended physical
expedited guidelines or or step counts
and so these
this group would be associate or is
associated with the highest risk of
experiencing the
adverse effects of being physically
inactive
okay
and as i mentioned this
the age was a little older for this
phenotype and that's in line with the
literature suggesting that the physical
activity levels actually decline over
the course of the lifespan so that
that's not too surprising
okay
so i'll mention one um another
interesting point so
consider phenotypes one two four right
the non-sanitary one um
groups
when you look at the aggregated
sedentary minutes they're actually
somewhat comparable for these three
phenotypes
and remember that i i said in the
earlier slide that phenotypes 2 and 4
are most likely to accumulate
the higher levels of at least moderate
intensity activity
this means that phenotype one is getting
more light intensity activity
now why is this interesting
so as i mentioned the physical activity
guidelines are now um slowly shifting
that there is more
focus on
not just the higher intensities but
rather any type of activity even light
intensity to replace sedentary minutes
and so this is kind of exciting why
because if you are working with an older
adult or someone who's coming from an
injury and you want to make a physical
activator recommendation
you don't have to force them to do
higher intensities of activity you can
still suggest you can still prescribe
lighter intensities of activity and this
person can still benefit still confer
the health benefits of being physically
active without over-exerting and because
like they will likely feel higher levels
of self-efficacy
about doing light intensity activity
they are more likely to adopt more
likely to maintain
this behavior
and more likely to then
experience the benefits okay
okay
okay so some takeaway points in some in
this work we use a
functional data analytic approach
specifically functional mixture models
to identify
um interoperable potentially clinically
meaningful clusters of daily physical
activity trajectories and a mixed sample
of adults over the life ages over the
lifespan
our models identify four phenotypes
which have been alluded to to some
extent in the literature so we have some
confidence to say that these are not
completely out there imaginary
archetypes that they do they do exist
out there in the population
and identification of such phenotypes
can see the first step towards designing
interventions
that are that are more efficacious and
that can be tailored at the right level
whether that is at the individual level
or subgroup level
um or in any other aspect
so that we can more adequately address
these behaviors
okay and with that i'd like to thank you
for listening and remind you to break
your sedentary time during the
conference by walking around
if you have you can reach out to me if
you have any questions i'll be around on
the break and you can connect with me
via social media or email
so thank you
you